TRUE, THAT WOULD MEAN, AND WE
HAVE A LOT MORE IN THE
INVESTIGATION PART TWO.
JOE BIDEN IN HIS OWN
IRREDEEMABLE AND DEPLORABLE
MOMENT.
HOW DO WE OPEN NEW YORK CITY MY
OWN THOUGHTS, AND I WILL SHARE
THEM FROM YOU.
ALSO, THIS QUESTION.
>> DOES THE STATEMENT HOLD FOR
YOU?
IF NOMINATED I WILL NOT ACCEPT,
IF DRAFTED I WILL NOT RUN, IF
ELECTED I WILL NOT SERVE.
>> Sean: THAT’S WHAT WE CALL A
T’S.
HE UNVEILED AND FINALLY HE HOPED
HE COULD MOVE ON.
THAT STARTING AS EARLY AS
MAY 1ST BUT ACTUALLY EARLY IN
SOME CASES.
SOUTH DAKOTA NEVER CLOSED AT
ALL, EVEN THE RESTAURANT STAYED
OPEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: BASED ON
THE LATEST DATA ARE A TEAM OF
EXPERTS NOW AGREE IS THAT WE CAN
BEGIN THE NEXT FRONT IN OUR WAR.
THAT’S HOW: OPENING UP AMERICA
AGAIN.
OUR NATIONAL SHUTDOWN IS NOT A
SUSTAINABLE LONG-TERM SOLUTION.
TO PRESERVE THE HEALTH OF OUR
CITIZENS, WE MUST ALSO PRESERVE
OURSELVES AND FUNCTIONING OF OUR
ECONOMY OVER THE LONG HAUL.
YOU CAN’T DO ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER.
THAT WILL ALLOW GOVERNORS TO
TAKE A PHASED AND DELIBERATE
APPROACH TO REOPENING THEIR
INDIVIDUAL STATES.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT I’M IN NEW YORK.
NEW YORK AND LONG ISLAND HARDEST
HIT IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT THEY CHOSE TO BACKS UP ALL
THEIR ITEMS, DAIRY AND IN
BETWEEN, AND THOSE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES DIDN’T SHUT DOWN.
AVEO PHARMACEUTICALS DIDN’T SHUT
DOWN, THOSE THAT BUILD THE MATH
AND GLOVES AND THE GALLONS OF
THE RESPIRATORS IN THE
VENTILATORS, THEY ALL WERE
WORKING.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY DIDN’T SHUT
DOWN.
THOSE ARE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
FOR EXAMPLE, DENSELY POPULATED
NEW YORK CITY WILL NOT BE ON THE
SAME TIMELINE AS MONTANA OR
SOUTH DAKOTA WHICH NEVER SHUT
DOWN ANYTHING.
INSTEAD OF A NATIONWIDE
SCHEDULE, THE PLAN HAS BEEN
BROKEN DOWN INTO THREE PHASES IN
ORDER FOR THE STATE TO BEGIN A
THREE-POINT PROCESS, IT HAS TO
SATISFY THAT.
GOVERNORS WAKE UP A LOT OF YOU,
SOME OF YOU ARE ASLEEP.
DO YOUR JOB.
THEY ARE NOW ASKED FOR THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS,
AND YOU GOT IT.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TASK FORCE
SEE THAT YOU’RE MESSING UP AND
HOT SPOTS ARE EMERGING, THEY
WILL COME DOWN HARD ON YOU.
PHASE ONE RECOMMENDS CONTINUED
RESTRICTIONS ON NONESSENTIAL
TRAVEL.
IT DISCOURAGES SOCIAL GATHERINGS
OF TEN OR MORE PEOPLE AND CALLS
FOR AMERICANS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK FROM HOME WHENEVER
POSSIBLE.
PHASE ONE ALSO RECOMMENDS LARGE
VENUES LIKE RESTAURANTS, MOVIE
THEATERS AND EVEN GYMS.
THEY CAN REOPEN BUT YOU HAVE TO
USE VERY STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOL WHICH WOULD
MEAN A LOT OF PUERILE AND A LOT
OF WIPES.
IF THE COVID-19 CURVE REMAINS
FLAT THEN YOU CAN MOVE TO PHASE
TWO.
THAT CONTINUES LIMITS ON
OCCUPANCY AND BARS WILL BE
TOUGH.
ULTIMATELY THE LAST STEP, PHASE
THREE, THAT WOULD LIFT STAFFING
RESTRICTIONS, AND THAT ALLOWS
VISITS TO SENIOR CARE FACILITIES
AND HOSPITALS TO BEGIN AGAIN,
EACH PHASE OF THE PLAN TO GET
AMERICANS BACK TO WORK WILL TAKE
EXTRA PRECAUTIONS.
NOW IN A PLACE LIKE
NEW YORK CITY.
IT’S A VERY SMALL GEOGRAPHIC
AREA, THE LARGEST CONCENTRATION
OF PEOPLE GOVERNOR CUOMO WAS ON
MY RADIO SHOW FOR AN HOUR AND WE
TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
I SHARED MY VIEWS AND HE SHARED
HIS.
IT WILL TAKE A LITTLE MORE WORK
IN A PLACE LIKE NEW YORK CITY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IT WILL BE A PHASING IN AND
IT’S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT.
I DON’T KNOW DIFFERENT WORDS, IT
MIGHT EVEN BE DIFFERENT BETTER
BUT IT’S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT.
THIS IS GOING TO DO WHAT 9/11
DATE.
IF I EVER TOLD YOU BEFORE 9/11
YOU WOULD HAVE TO TAKE OFF YOUR
SHOES WHEN YOU GO TO AN AIRPORT
AND WALK THROUGH A METAL
DETECTOR ON A LINE AND HAVE THEM
GO THROUGH YOUR BAGS, PEOPLE
WOULD SAY NO HOW, NO WAY.
BUT 9/11 CHANGED OUR
ORIENTATION.
THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE OUR
ORIENTATION AND PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO WANT TO CHANGE.
PEOPLE WANT TO BE SAFE, FIRST OF
ALL.
>> Sean: SOME OF THIS IS
ANNOYING, NOBODY WANTS TO WEAR
GLOVES AND A MASK BUT FOR THE
TIME BEING -- WE ARE ALSO DOING
IT FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE.
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS AND
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DAYS
NEW YORK HAS SEEN ACTUALLY,
FINALLY, TREMENDOUS PROCESS
PROGRESS.
THE MODELS ARE HOLDING AS WE
HOPED THEY WOULD.
HOSPITALIZATIONS DROPPED BY 600
WHICH IS THE LARGEST DECREASE TO
DATE.
TOTAL INTEGRATIONS DROPPED BY
40, ALSO THE LARGEST DECREASE
AND THE DEATH RATE IS STARTING
TO DECLINE, THAT IS THE LAGGING
INDICATOR AS WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT.
FOR THIS PROGRESS TO CONTINUE IN
A PLACE THAT’S DENSELY POPULATED
AS NEW YORK CITY, I KNOW IT
SUCKS.
RESIDENTS THERE WILL NEED TO
TAKE IMPORTANT PRECAUTIONARY
MEASURES.
IF YOU WANT MY PLAN, WE WILL
CALL THE HANNITY PLAN.
TO REOPEN NEW YORK CITY WOULD BE
THE FOLLOWING.
MASKS AND GLOVES MIGHT BE THE
NEW NORMAL IN NEW YORK CITY,
EVEN INDOORS.
NONESSENTIAL WORKERS, THEY WILL
HAVE TO WORK FROM HOME.
AT LEAST 50% OF THE WORKFORCE IN
EVERY BUILDING IN NEW YORK, 50%
IS THE GOAL.
KEEP THEM WORKING AT HOME AND
THAT ALLOWS MORE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
LESS CONCENTRATION ON THE
STREETS IN THE BUILDINGS OF
NEW YORK CITY.
DIGITAL TEMPERATURE CHECKS.
THEY DON’T TOUCH YOU, BUT THE
THING ON YOUR FOR HEDDA, BOOM.
THAT SHOULD BE MANDATORY AGAIN,
TEMPORARILY.
IF YOU WANT ENTRANCE INTO ANY
BUILDING IN NEW YORK CITY.
I DISCUSSED ALL OF THIS WITH THE
GOVERNOR TODAY.
I WANT TO SEE YANKEE STADIUM
OPEN.
I WANT CITI FIELD WHERE THE METS
PLAY OPEN.
I WANT METLIFE STADIUM IN
NEW JERSEY OPEN FOR THE GIANTS
AND JETS.
NOW THIS IS NOT MY DECISION, BUT
YOU HAVE TO START WITH THIS ONE
THING.
PEOPLE MOST AT RISK WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH ISSUES OR
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS,
GUYS, YOU SHOULDN’T GO, NOT THIS
YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A YEAR OFF.
EVERY PLAYER, EVERY TRAINER,
EVERY COACH, EVERY TICKET TAKER,
EVERY FOOD AND BEVERAGE WORKER
WILL HAVE TO HAVE THAT ADDED
FIVE-MINUTE TEST.
ANYONE THAT WANTS TO ATTEND
AGAIN.
NOW IF I HAVE A CHOICE OF
ATTENDING A GAME AND NOT
ATTENDING A GAME, AND I’M JUST
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF, CONSULT A
DOCTOR, I’M NOT A DOCTOR.
BUT YOU MUST GET THE TEMPERATURE
TEST TO GET INTO YANKEE STADIUM.
IF YOU HAVE A TEMPERATURE, YOU
THEY GIVE YOU THE INFORMATION,
GO TO HER DOCTOR, BE SAFE AT
HOME, HOW TO DO CONTACT TRACING.
YOU CAN’T HAVE A DATABASE, YOU
HAVE TO RESPECT PRIVACY, BUT IF
YOU HAVE A TEMPERATURE YOU CAN’T
GO IT INTO EVEN AN OUTDOOR
STADIUM.
NOW TEMPORARILY, AGAIN NOT THE
BEST CONDITIONS BUT IF IT’S MY
CHOICE, AND IF I HAVE TO WEAR
GLOVES AND A MASK, OKAY.
I WILL WEAR IT.
I’D RATHER GO AND WEAR IT.
IF EVERYONE ELSE IS WEARING IT
WE CAN SET UP FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS UNTIL THINGS HAVE PASSED.
YOU PROBABLY CAN’T EAT POPCORN
BUT YOU COULD PROBABLY EAT A
HOT DOG.
OPEN UP YOUR RESPIRATOR COME AND
TAKE BITE AND YOU CHEW IT UNDER
YOUR MASK.
I HAVE TO DRINK MY BEER IF I’M
AT A GAME SO IF I HAVE TO USE A
STRAW AND SLIP IT IN, I WILL DO
THAT.
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO GET MY
BEER, I WANT TO HAVE A BEER.
EVERYONE HAS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISION.
WHAT IS YOUR APPETITE FOR RISK?
YOU GET IN A CAR AND IT’S A
RISK.
CONSULT WITH YOUR DOCTOR.
I’D RATHER HAVE MY TEMPERATURE
TAKEN, DRINK BEER FROM A STRAW,
EAT A HOT DOG BY GOING LIKE THIS
AND CHEWING IT WITH A MASK THAN
NOT GOING AT ALL.
I’M PRO-CHOICE AND I KNOW THIS
IS NOT IDEAL BUT IF IT’S ABOUT
SAVING THE LIVES ESPECIALLY OF
OTHER PEOPLE MORE VULNERABLE AND
GETTING OUR ECONOMY BACK UP AND
RUNNING FULL SPEED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, I WILL SUCK IT UP.
AND I THINK A LOT OF NEW YORKERS
WOULD SUCK IT UP AND WANT TO GO
TO THE GAME, WHERE THE MASK AND
GLOVES AND BEAT THE YANKEES AND
THE GIANTS AND JETS AND METS CAN
MAKE THEIR OWN MASKS AND HAND
THEM OUT AS YOU GO IN WITH THEIR
EMBLEMS ON IT.
MEDICAL PRIVACY IS A MUST.
IT CAN’T BE COMPROMISED.
NO GOVERNMENT DATABASES, SORRY.
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
PEOPLE CAN DECIDE TO GO OR NOT
GO BASED ON THESE TEMPORARY
RULES AND I CHOOSE TO GO.
SAME WITH FOOTBALL, SAME WITH
OUTDOOR CONCERTS, AND INDOOR
EVENTS?
WHILE I THINK YOU COULD MOVE THE
NEW YORK RANGERS AND ISLANDERS
TO YANKEE STADIUM AND CITY
FIELD, THEY DO THAT ONCE A YEAR
ANYWAY.
A RECENT POLL SHOWS THAT SOME
DEMOCRATS, THE MAJORITY OF THEM,
WOULD LIKELY SUPPORT MANDATORY